all right let's review this week's
mailbag if you have a message for me you
can email it to info
davidpakman.com many many messages come
in every week uh i think
probably
a thousand or so
and we can only look at you know 10 or
so so just understand that please be
polite please be respectful info
davidpakman.com all right first email
this week came in from christopher who
also signed his email keith
i don't know a christopher says
after this weekend's trump rally
you talk crap about trump how much is
your gas now compared to when trump was
in office well i drive an electric car
so my gas hasn't changed but i
understand the point
how about your grocery bill yes it's
higher
but what does joe biden have to do with
that
how about everything you buy bring way
up with the democratic leadership
don't understand why you dummies can't
look at numbers instead of your personal
political opinion f biden and fu well
that's exactly what i do
regardless of my political opinion which
is i prefer biden to trump
i have to look at the numbers when it
comes to gas prices inflation
etc
and when i look at the numbers i see
that those things are up all over the
world
and i see that
those are
not phenomena
that depend on the american president to
any significant degree we've i'm not
going to do
i respect you too much in the audience
to do my what can presidents do
about gas prices rant a second third
what must be probably the fifth time now
so i'm not going to do that but it is
exactly because i do look at the facts
that i come to the conclusions i come to
and christopher
or
keith i don't know is welcome to call
into my show anytime
and we can talk about it
next gil
wrote in
also about the trump rally over the
weekend
and said you seem to laugh at donald
trump
i think you don't know very much
usa is a corporation
usa inc since yesterday usa
become a republic like if was before
and one more thing
donald know more than you
about political rules in michigan well i
couldn't possibly say it any better
myself and this is just such a wholesale
destruction
of my ideology and world view that i
won't even try to respond to guil
because it's just too much i just it's
just overwhelming
okay next email is from darius darius
says new subscriber here
you killed air
with darlene
david i stumbled on your youtube videos
a couple of years ago and have been
evangelizing you to my friends and
finally decided it's time to pay
for solid journalism so i am now a
subscriber supporting the work you do i
love it just remember i do commentary
not journalism important distinction
darius goes on to say however
your interview with diana swafford it
was darlene swafar okay but it doesn't
matter i know who you mean
put you in the category
of why doesn't this guy have his own
msnbc or cnn show
your interview
oh boy was absolutely brilliant you were
respectful even complementary your poker
face was amazing and critical to keep
her from walking off you parse the oil
issue brilliantly dude you need an agent
to up your game and get a broadcast
cable show this country needs people
like you please try to do more
interviews like these well i really
appreciate that i have an agent we are
not trying to get me on msnbc or cnn or
fox or whatever i'm very happy with what
i'm doing i don't want to have 10 bosses
at any of those places i don't think
they want me there either but i so
appreciate
the kind words from darius about this
and we are trying to get more of those
interviews lined up with the
2020 candidates on the right and on the
left we're doing it all
we're doing it all
next let's go to an email from teresa
teresa said is there a way i can gift
more than one membership at a time
david said on air that there were over
600 hoping to become members i'd like to
offer several gifts anonymously thank
you yeah so teresa is asking a perfect
question
one of the biggest things people in the
audience wanted was they wanted to be
able to gift memberships on our website
they would write in they would say sir i
have a membership
but i want to give some memberships away
can i do that and up until two weeks ago
the answer was no
but we listened we have a new plugin on
our website joinpakman.com which when
you go through the checkout now there's
a box and it says is this a gift and if
you check the box your membership will
be added to our queue which we can give
away we've given away about a hundred
memberships so far thanks to gifts but
we do have now it's not even 600 it's
now 670 people waiting for a membership
so we are going to try teresa to make
this a possibility where you can just do
10 at a time 20 at a time 30 you know
just dump memberships in we're going to
try but in the meantime you can still
gift individual memberships one at a
time what a generous audience beautiful
spencer wrote in about my use of the
term bad faith
spencer says hey david i've been
watching your show for well over a year
now and have a request
that seems simple but it may take some
time to elaborate on the answer
could you give a definition or
explanation on the phrase bad faith in
terms of political questions and
comments i personally haven't had an
issue agreeing with you whenever you use
it but it may help others understand why
you use that phrase to dismiss certain
talking points and ideas from both the
right and left so here's the thing
there's two answers about what we mean
by bad faith
the first one is you sort of know bad
faith when you see it and what i mean by
that is you might remember
when i appeared on the
uh jessie lee peterson show
and he asked me what is love
and i knew that it was a bad faith
question to try to wrap me up into some
kind of homophobic thing and so i didn't
even take it seriously i said you know
oh jesse you know love when you see it
it's sort of ethereal and i i don't know
what i said i just kind of laughed
laughed it off but what we mean by bad
faith is that there's an intent to
deceive or that you are not being
genuine in your intention so to give an
example
when marsha blackburn asks
judge now just soon to be justice
katanji brown jackson
what is a woman
it's not that by definition asking what
a woman is is a bad faith question a
five-year-old would ask lots of
questions that are just they don't have
the information yet what is a woman okay
great or a three-year-old i don't know
when kids ask what's a woman what's a
man
but the point of the question
is deceptive it's not a mere curiosity
it's a bad faith in uh attempt to get
judge jackson to pigeonhole herself with
one definition which will then be turned
and used against her for political
reasons so with bad faith you have to
understand context bad faith is sort of
like a dog whistle
the idea of a dog whistle is the same
way that if you blow a dog whistle the
dogs hear it but humans don't or at
least not as loud okay
it's the same type of thing with dog
whistles where if i say if you didn't
understand listen imagine that you're
from
a a society that has not had contact
with
the west call it okay
and i say to you
yeah you know
i'm trying to think of a good example if
i say to you yeah
there's a we're going to look into
the people that control hollywood
like george soros
and steven spielberg right and i list a
bunch of jewish people
unless you know what to listen for
you don't realize that that's an
anti-semitic trope
and much like with a dog whistle you
have to be conditioned to hear it you
also have to understand context to be
able to identify bad faith questions i
hope that i'm being clear
i hope that i'm being clear in this but
uh an important question for sure
dave wrote in
and dave says uh about my story on
republican covid deaths
david you should have mentioned their
base is substantially older than the
democrats i would bet out of the 73 000
florida deaths you mentioned you can add
another 20 000 because they are older
voters 60s to 90s i bet 60 percent of
republican at least great show yeah we
we don't we just don't have the numbers
the question here is about the partisan
death gap in covid we know it skews
towards republicans we just don't know
by how much and we don't know if by
enough to make a difference in any
midterm elections but i welcome any
information we might have about that
keith wrote in with an idea here's an
idea from keith david sir as your show
is an independent operation i know
maintaining a workable revenue stream is
an ongoing effort i have a one word
solution for you
reruns reruns made the creators of shows
like friends and seinfeld billionaires
or very nearly so why not you reruns
david reruns well i appreciate the
support keith but there is a difference
between the marble rye and its replay
value as a seinfeld episode
and what was in the news on august 10th
of uh 2012
there's not that much replay value to
news shows so i love the idea in
practice i don't know if it works but
what does work is
we will sometimes weave together themed
episodes where we say let's take the
issue of climate and make an episode out
of our best interviews about climate
change we've done that and people
generally like it so that works just
reruns reruns i just don't know
they're good for a few months but i
don't think anyone's going to buy them
but i appreciate the uh thinking about
how to grow revenue last email today is
from doug
who also
signs his email brian i i don't know why
people do this
anyway it doesn't matter
doug says david please refrain from
using the phrase guys or you guys
it's disrespecting the women in your
audience consider using folks or you
folks yet this is a regional thing
in in new england it's very con growing
up you just you just used guys
it was inclusive of everybody
um and
i'd never used folks i never used use
i never used uh
y'all
um i i certainly don't intend to
disrespect any women
but if you agree with doug or brian
maybe you agree with brian and disagree
with doug i have no idea this is from
doug brian if you agree disagree let me
know your thoughts is it offensive when
i casually say
guys i don't know if i can take this
republican bs anymore am i being
disrespectful to women when i say that
let me know we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today sign up at join
joinpackman.com to instantly access the
bonus show also remember that on tuesday
april 19
6 pm eastern we'll be doing the next
david pakman show viewer town hall it
will be live only on our second youtube
channel pacman live that's youtube.com
pacmanlive